walter has sealed himself indoors while
being after being recognized by a
reporter visiting the prison while
hiding he's visited by an incessant
local food critic who attempts to get
him to open up about the death row
prisoner he's been trying to help
interior Walters home night on screen a
late night news show sanedo you've got
one of the most promising young chefs in
the country just disappears one day and
pops up 20 years later feeding guys on
death row take another look at this
photo that went viral earlier today the
photo Walter a tender look as he shakes
hands with Reid shirtless and raw-boned
the tray between them Walter stares at
the TV from his chair despondent
drinking now no comment from carrot yet
as to his position in the case but we're
told the inmate Jeffrey Reed is striking
in protest of his execution three weeks
from now folks this is North Carolina
but look at him this looks more like
something out of a brave a knock at the
door Walter mutes the TV at the door
Walter peers wearily warily through the
drapes reluctantly he opens the door
it's henna I figured you could use a
drink got one he shuts the door Hannah
blocks it open with a bottle not like
this Walter Reed's the label from his
expression it's a nice one he disappears
inside with it but leaves the door open
interior Walters home later the to
recline in the living room red-faced
shoes off left the Correspondents Dinner
and wandered into the kitchen said the
speeches were boring you know everyone
thinks the bad thing his idea wait
you're the one who told Ozzy Osbourne to
eat the head off a bet Wow not just the
head I told him about the native soup
recipe from Guam the bad part he
remembered he just forgot the soup
Walter points to her empty glass another
please Walter takes their glasses to the
bar Reagan December 8th 87 stayed dinner
with Mikhail Gorbachev Walter looks over
his shoulder hannah has found a blue
book beside the chair looking up from
the page in awe that night they ended
the Cold War Nixon 1970
in honor of our guests Elvis Presley LBJ
july second 1964 Civil Rights Act
reception dr. Martin Luther King jr.
this is every presidential meal since
Kennedy he heard the first of us well
Jackie Jackie did really chef's always
the first lady's choice book started
with Renee who left it to Henry and so
on every occasion imaginable sort of a
playbook a playbook if every if one of
us ever got stuck so why didn't you pass
it down cuz I'm a sore loser do you miss
it Walter considers an answer four
points to the muted TV instead on screen
footage of the crowd outside the prison
Oh get it he's been on the hunger strike
for two weeks why care now hunger
strikes aren't new you are Walter I
could have written about you before but
I didn't I know so between you and me
why are you talking to read on Walter at
the point of stepping back or forward
cuz I believe in him the guy was caught
on tape flipping the switch you know
that right Reed says there's more to the
tape weeks maybe months of footage that
they never showed in court and if it did
show up suka asked him to do it why
wouldn't his lawyer use it not and how
do you explain the safe I can't but you
still believe him I do why have you ever
heard of something called marasmus it's
a condition when a child starts to go
hungry the muscles atrophy the stomach
distends bones start to break a normal
ten-year-old should weigh about 80
pounds I wait 50 my dad would keep well
then there weren't the social services
then that there are now but food was
something momentous to me when someone
sends it back wasting it upsets me but
eating it that that's why I cook I don't
say that for your empathy but so you'll
understand that I know what hunger feels
like it's like a rut the most unen stink
shellacked a human can do is not eat and
read is deciding to rot I can't make
sense of that unless he's telling the
truth a long beat ana lifts her glass
drinks until it's gone we'll need to
file a Freedom of Information Act
request why for the tape it'll probably
take a few weeks to get the full copy
from the evidence are you sure still
even exists I mean it's a 2 10 year old
trial evidence in a capital murder case
can't be destroyed until three years
after the death of the defendant that's
in three weeks Hannah rises to leave
Walter regards are impressed I thought
you were a food creek and I thought you
were a prison cook not some shining
Knight of political and justice this
isn't political huh tell them that